Nobody saw these flicks coming.
From an MCU darling trading his Avenger buds
in for some furry friends to a 21st century
take on a buzz-worthy horror classic, these
are just some of the most surprising, unexpected,
and straight-up bizarre movies hitting theatres
in 2020.
Dr. Dolittle is a character with a weird history.
The physician who could talk with animals
was created by author Hugh Lofting in letters
written home to his children from the trenches
of World War I.
The character would go on to become the star
of a series of popular children's books, set
in Victorian England and published from the
1920s through the '50s.
A number of adaptations appeared over the
following decades, including cartoons, radio
plays, stage productions, and a lavish 1967
movie musical starring Rex Harrison.
When modern audiences see the name "Dolittle,"
however, they probably think back to the 1998
movie starring Eddie Murphy, which became
something of a franchise all its own, spawning
such intriguingly titled direct-to-DVD sequels
as Tail to the Chief.
Now, the good doctor is returning to the big
screen in the form of… wait for it…
Robert Downey Jr.
The animal cast will be voiced by a star-studded
lineup that includes Rami Malek, John Cena,
Emma Thompson, Octavia Spencer, Tom Holland,
Selena Gomez, and Ralph Fiennes.
We know exactly what you thinking: Where
in the world did this one come from?
We don't exactly have an answer for ya - but
after over a decade rocking that Iron-Man
suit, maybe RDJ just needed to lighten things
up a little bit.
It is the destiny of all horror franchises
to be rebooted.
That's been the case for pretty much the entire
21st century so far - since the dawn of the
new millennium, we've seen remakes and reimaginings
of The Texas Chainsaw Massacre, A Nightmare
on Elm Street, Friday the 13th, and multiple
stabs - pun intended - at a new Halloween.
"Please, dear god!
Please!
Help me!
Please help me!"
Another long-dormant series seems ready for
similar treatment.
Candyman, released in 1992, was based on a
story by Hellraiser creator Clive Barker and
starred Tony Todd as a supernatural killer
who haunted a housing project in Chicago and
represented the specter of racial and class
inequality.
Also, bees came out of his mouth.
It's weird and socially conscious and freaking
awesome.
"She said his name the last time."
"Candyman."
"She turned out the lights."
And it's perfect material for the shockingly
prolific Jordan Peele, who is producing and
co-writing a new Candyman slated to hit theaters
in 2020.
Bloody Disgusting reports that the film, directed
by up-and-comer Nia DaCosta, will be a "spiritual
sequel" that returns to the now-gentrified
neighborhood of the original.
Casting remains unannounced, but Todd is angling
to be involved in some capacity.
One of the most intriguing cinematic developments
of 2018 was the launch of Sony's new generation
of Spider-Man movies.
Having successfully partnered with Marvel
to bring Tom Holland's live-action Peter Parker
to the MCU, the studio has set out to keep
their own stake in the Spidey brand alive
with a slate of spinoffs and animated titles.
The first two examples, Venom and Into the
Spider-Verse, proved that they were ready
to explore a variety of unique and vastly
different facets of the webhead's corner of
the Marvel Universe.
Work quickly began on sequels to both Venom
and Spider-Verse, though no firm dates for
those follow-ups have been officially announced.
Sony has, however, confirmed a 2020 release
for Morbius, starring the, quote, "Living
Vampire" who has faced off with Spider-Man
in comics since the '70s.
Nope - we didn't see that one coming either.
Daniel Espinosa is on board to direct, with
a script by Dracula Untold writers Matt Sazama
and Burk Sharpless.
Jared Leto will star as the titular bloodsucker,
with former Doctor Who actor Matt Smith appearing
in a major role and True Detective star Adria
Arjona as love interest Martine Bancroft.
Coming to America was released in 1988, at
the height of Eddie Murphy's superstardom.
Murphy, who co-wrote the story, stars as Prince
Akeem, heir to the throne of the fictional
African nation of Zamunda.
Determined to escape an arranged marriage
and find a free-thinking bride to fall in
love with, he travels to New York City with
trusted aide Semmi in tow.
It was a box office smash, capping off an
explosively successful decade for Murphy.
"I've warned you.
I'll be forced to thrash you."
"F--- you!"
After a period of rumors and rumblings, a
Coming to America sequel has been officially
announced and set to be released in 2020.
You heard that right: Akeem is coming BACK
to America after 30 years, and this time he's
searching for his long-lost son.
Original supporting players Arsenio Hall,
Shari Headley, John Amos, and James Earl Jones
are all rumored to be in talks as well.
Black-ish creator Kenya Barris is penning
the screenplay, with Craig Brewer taking the
director's chair from the original movie's
John Landis.
Not only are Roald Dahl's stories enduring
works of literature, they've also been adapted
by a staggeringly eclectic lineup of filmmakers
- Steven Spielberg, Tim Burton, Wes Anderson,
and Danny DeVito to name a few.
In 2020, Robert Zemeckis will join that lineup
with a new take on The Witches.
This 1983 children's novel tells the story
of an orphaned boy who goes to live with his
grandmother, a retired witch hunter.
The pair must battle an international coven
of witches poised to turn England's children
into mice.
The Witches has been made into a movie once
before, in 1990.
That production had a stellar array of talent,
with acclaimed director Nicolas Roeg at the
helm, Jim Henson on board as producer, and
a delightfully wicked performance from Anjelica
Huston.
The film was received enthusiastically by
critics, though Dahl, enraged by alterations
to his story, called it "utterly appalling."
Zemeckis' Witches is already shaping up to
have an impressive pedigree of its own.
Not only is the man behind Back to the Future
and Forrest Gump taking on writing and directing
duties, but Guillermo del Toro and Alfonso
Cuarón are producing, and Anne Hathaway is
attached to star as the Grand High Witch.
The Witches will enchant theaters in the 2020
Halloween season.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.